[Music]
people were chanting Conan right now but
a lot of people were also chanting
Supreme Court decision on health care
there they are right over there
people are electrified by this story
young people they're chanting it they're
talking about it and here's the latest
there's talk that the Supreme Court may
issue their upcoming decision on health
care reform on live television did you
hear this when they decided maybe on
live television yeah and to boost
ratings each judge will give their
decision after spinning around in their
chair to face the camera
[Applause]
I think the Supreme Court should do that
all the time on every decision that
would get all of us interested again
don't you think
absolutely get CeeLo on the court
[Laughter]
President Obama has issued an order
allowing some illegal immigrants to stay
in the United States
yeah Mitt Romney says he's fine with
this plan at least until his landscaping
is finished
[Applause]
this is crazy controversy in Michigan
several male politicians have banned a
female politician from speaking on the
House floor because she used the word
vagina yeah it's not that they don't
want her to say it it's if they wanted
to say it's slower while unbuttoning her
blouse true story yesterday Microsoft
unveiled a new tablet called surface
yeah
microsoft says it shows the name surface
because it's a great place to put your
ipad
[Applause]
hey get this in an ish yeah I just want
to try that out right right
from now on before joke hey gang get
this no one else does that it gives them
time to put their hand in here I saw
people in the audience go yeah
hey gang gather round that's another one
I could do I've got the skinny guy the
round guy these are things I'm trying
out every night just to change it up
maybe doing this in an interview with
Oprah Kim Kardashian said she fell into
a deep depression because of her divorce
yeah then Oprah said she fell into a
deep depression because she was
interviewing Kim Kardashian
[Applause]
can't believe you gave me an award for
that job it's fantastic right there hey
gang did you hear this adidas adidas is
discontinuing a pair of sneakers that
critics are calling racist racist
sneakers yeah so today may be your last
chance to buy a pair of air Mel Gibson's
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
researchers have found that several baby
shampoos listen this baby shampoos can
cause newborns to test positive for
marijuana yeah so moms think twice
before you wash your baby's hair with
pen teens green apple gunga stank how
did they find this out like yeah that's
the bigger question is using be who's
testing babies for marijuana baby look
ah yeah that's the part we should be
investing yeah here's a kooky story
check this out gang a Belgian man has
built an exact replica of Luke
Skywalker's childhood home
yeah yeah when asked what his wife
thinks the man said wife that's a good
one
you